[Music]
i recommend putting aside our
differences for now
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
isn't that why we formed the justice
league to do what's right
protecting the monsters look who you're
standing
everyone has to make their own choice
about this oh so now he's god from what
i've heard most of the magical heroes
feel the same way superman you've had an
unfathomable loss you need time to
process
let yourself fall apart
you took his wife
you took his unborn child
why after all these years betsy you
really need reasons from me
now that's
a french line
what happened to metropolis can never be
allowed to occur again
i won't be held back by ideals that
don't protect the innocent
you'll throw away everything the justice
league stands for
you're his best friend talk to him
superman has created a police state he
needs to be stopped the laws of superman
will not be the laws of atlantis this
time
the jokes are new
i thought i could redeem you
i was wrong
[Music]
you